the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so
first I was saying I think you should
start thinking about the project and the
water I'm looking for is a short report
paper type report I want to limit the
only five pages okay
and it could be anything related to this
subject right so if you happen to be
working on something you want to extend
and apply the knowledge they learn in
this subject you're welcome to do so and
in fact I wrote a paper based on term
paper I was working on one with a
graduate student I thought that that's
that was a good experience
in fact the turns out to be the first
paper on thermal conductivity of quantum
wells I was taking a long linear optics
course I spend the whole semester and at
the end I went to professor's I don't
understand what you talk and he was a
term paper and I said how about he was
talking about da beside the Feynman
diagram so I still don't quite
understand what it would say the Feynman
diagram but so I said how bother I
worked on paper on quantum well thermal
kinetic analysis a fine that's fine
so I wrote the term paper and I
continued to work hard and I eventually
actually Papaji a paper on the thermal
conductivity of quantum Wells and
looking back there because of the assay
I was doing pretty much it boards my
equation so completely forgot of
contestation but turns out most of the
stuff were correct
not everything was correct and so what I
want this is I encourage you to think
about subject relate to your research it
can spin
that or if you you not say you don't
have a subject that you can do a
literature review let me say you're
interested in a specific topic let's say
metamaterials or plasmonics or any any
of the sin that the wit mission or you
read right you are going to apply the
knowledge you can do a literature review
and expand that maybe you say okay based
on that and maybe this is a interesting
problem that I can continue working on
you can work after this semester you can
always do you always welcome to discuss
with me and if you really do I say don't
have a topic come talk to me I think I
can always figure something we can
negotiate and say what would you would
be interesting okay so that's on the
term paper my so now you have all turned
in I see you first
create a first midterm and redo it any
questions on those first midterm
I think say when I was looking at where
were Muslim mistakes made I think one of
this is the the depths of the evil
lesson way right and probably because
unless you go back are you reading dung
and it may not be easy to figure out
what's the depth but say the K is you
should be able to write down the plan
wave expressions right and if you have
the plane wave expression and you use
your snail law and you can find the
angle when the angle cosine theta sine
theta is larger than one so you use your
cosine theta 1 square root of 1 minus
that sciency that square and they plug
in the plan where you should be able to
find out what's the penetration depth
all for the evil Essen way and there was
another question about the what's the
number of molecules having certain speed
right that's a gas molecule and so
they're I would guess probably you might
be guests talking what's a total number
of just need to start with the total
number of molecules right per unit
volume and that's the first day you need
to given temperature given pressure you
could use the ideal gas law to find out
what's the bokor density and then use a
maxwell velocity distribution to say
what's the total number with the number
of molecules that have a certain
velocity and then i think it is a matter
of time most of you couldn't finish the
math problem where we're looking at the
photon see the coolant of poland
distribution to the blackbody radiation
words they peak winds displacement snow
right so you find out that in many case
a low temperature yeah you do have a
peak but a high temperature that
wavelength equivalents too short
compared to times the lattice constant
so you actually ever reach that peak it
would be you you should continue to try
that out
and for many years i haven't done that
myself on here this time as i have to
make a problem out of it this is the
optical absorption that's the second
longer problem what's the optical
absorption for direct gap semiconductor
and it's a matter of joint density of
states
so if I have right so I have a
semiconductor dispersion and I have
photon this is the Nifty electron from
the valence band to conduction band and
then you need to say this is my photon
energy H Omega mule and how is it
related to okay so you you need to fire
first write down because you know this
parabola is parabola and the difference
of this two energy gives you the photon
energy right so once you have photon
energy or frequency versus K and you can
use the normal way we do density of
states because the absorption depends on
how many states you have and this is an
in fact that called the joint density of
states between the valence band and
conduction band and they turns out is
same as your bulk material that stays
square root of emails is at the back gap
right so the absorption of the light for
the pure semiconductor this is this
curve of absorption is a reflection of
the joint density of states and of
course you have the population right we
didn't say okay you have to say how many
electrons here
how many Amplatz States here if I do it
I really need to say this is the F and
here F for the library electron here
here is empty so so that's a 1 minus F
that's a different F because there if
you coming up with insurers here and you
see the say Fermi Dirac is say energy
minus meal and here is the valence band
energy mass mueller-wright so basically
if you force yourself going through
those problems many times you can
understand a lot of the basics that you
say and I let I did not do this before
and
I this time I said I give you problems I
have first period that's it any
questions okay ah so should not that
let's come back and if we think what
we're talking the last time we talk
about this way to the particle
transition and from that other we say
from now I'm going to neglect the face
of the energy carriers they plan wave
and current no longer care in the face
and just look at the trajectory and
tritium eyes billables right so look at
the trajectory and for that we say we
discuss briefly the Nobel equation which
is the M particle distribution function
and that I say it's a of course they're
adding is a huge number of particle in
my system and we say okay from this
lowboy equation there are january to
approach one is the board's my equation
that's the say long developed and the
other is the linear response theory
which i hope i had will have time and in
to cover some if you do molecular
dynamics
you should really dive into linear
response theory that's the analysis I
commented a lot of people in fact say
any undergraduate student coming can
conceptually understand equal F equals
MA do a simulation but the case you have
to really understand that they the basis
for that and so we move on and say okay
from F 2 n + 2 F of 1 that's a one part
of your distribution function that's a
boards my equation and the FN is just
the multiplication of what F 1 for n
particles and we they because of for the
one particle now this particular were
correct with the rest of the particle in
the system so they boys my equation
which you roughly can show from Nova
equation the left-hand side is DF DT the
first derivative because here is the
steel of functioning in phase space
right F is the distribution functions do
function in phase space so the first
derivative is gradient as with respect
to space the second gradient is with
respect to the momentum right and it's
actually interested in the comment the F
it looks like a function of XYZ V X V Y
VZ it looks like it has a duration we
actually have is if a particle is going
certain to Russian I have different F
right so but see the question is a
vector or scalar what do you think it's
a scalar in high dimensional space right
and if you just think about an in point
in space and part of you're going
specific at the russian have specific
distribution so that looks like it has
directional properties but that
direction property is really the way
coordinate the higher dimensional
coordinate space cos a phase space
coordinate okay and also there are
different ways to write this force term
DP DT is the same day if you look at
thing about the Newton's law DP DT gives
you the F the force and the force you
can write an F say because P is a MA mm
way so I can put them em out and the F
sader idiot derivative with respect to V
or P is the function of H K right so by
I can use different variables rather
than using P I can use the V I can use K
and a different way of writing this term
and that's most of time
say when you deal with the electrons you
have to keep this term that's the
important driving force for the electron
motion well with your photon or photon
we do not need this term or even see the
molecules there's no direct force and
then ah but the complication is really
on this left-hand side the right-hand
side where I see the now the part of
your interact with the rest of the
particle and that's the collision term
so let's move on and that try to write
down this collision term because so far
looks all pretty simple on the right
hand side left hand side you can see
it's the first order derivative right
and so let's look harder the collision
term df/dt
this is not a derivative with just a
symbol how we can express it and
normally I can start just to consider
the two particle collision and so if I
have two particles interact with each
other and this is initially this
particle has the energy and momentum of
a vector right HK is the momentum and
this outer particular has a EE 1 K 1 and
when they get close to the interaction
range what is close to interaction range
and say if you think about - gasps I say
atoms
it's the electron when the electrostatic
potential clean interact with each other
right so you have electrons you have new
clay so you have that that's where they
start to interact so if you think about
the gas molecules in this room we see
the averaging mean free possible 100
nanometer right and the the atomic size
is a few angstroms
so there is actually a very large space
in between the most times they do not
interact they were just travel freely
and when they're getting really close to
each other
you got this collision right also due to
the collision you will have the energy
change maybe right and you are changing
a direction so that's the final state
for this first particle and you have the
energy change of second particle and
momentum change of the second particle
right and in a typical problem what do
you want to say okay what's the first
step what do they read awful what's the
probability what's the rate right and
the way to do this is a approximate
method so if you have originally if you
solve a matter for example if I have
photon comes in and getting absorbed by
the matures getting absorbed by material
right so originally the matura has a
certain energy and that's the quantum
economy as to the solutions allowable
energy levels that's what we did in the
second chapter right so we our region
our problem this system before
interacting has the energy and the
corresponding e we can write a
Schrodinger equation essentially we can
write the Hamiltonian which is the
kinetic energy so H bar square 2m k and
so it's a the operator that's the first
term in the Schrodinger equation right
and plus u zero right so when we show
solve the Schrodinger equation we say
this one equals mass I h-bar I h-bar D
psi D DT we solve for the energy states
right so now what I have so this is with
it of steady state problem
now during a photon comes in what it
does is to create a perturbation you
treat it as a small perturbation to the
original Hamiltonian H so ah let's say
this is your H zero and the small
perturbation let's say they now the
interaction Hamiltonian H is H zero plus
a small perturbation which could be a
function R and T right this is the
interaction term this is the original
unperturbed where I already have suppose
you already have the Schrodinger
equation solution you know the energy
level you know that we function the
state quantum states of the original
system right and due to this
perturbation you go back to the
Schrodinger equation you solve using
perturbation method we're not going to
do it and with that you can find the
rate of perturbation due to this
perturbation the system changing from
one state to the other and this rate is
the transition rate this is a former
initial state to a final state right and
this is a 2 pi H bar and we have the
integration of the final state wave
function complex conjugate the
perturbation so this is the the
unperturbed system that we function
let's suppose that you started with a
certain initial state and we function
and the final state wave function that's
suppose you already have solving the
original problem and now given this
perturbation Hamiltonian and I have the
initial state we
function and I interact integrate over
the volume of the interaction and this
is square and then a delta function e
I'm a CF which says they are initial
energy the energy conservation Delta
function is zero when the e is not
equally F right so only when AI equals
CF this is a non zero so essentially
what this gives us is the energy
conservation of the system and if you do
this if you say when you do the wave
function for plan wave you have wave
vector right for each quantum state you
have V vector and if you do the
integration of this you'll also find a
corresponding conservation in with
vector that's your momentum conservation
so what you have essentially you will
get the momentum energy conservation
from this transition rate and so they
are you have for example the initial
energy so this is the two particle
interacting so this is the initially es
function okay and the incoming ye1 k1
equals e prime K Prime you go scatter
into another state and the e 1 prime K 1
Prime and C so that's the energy
contribution this is the Delta function
the initial of the two system to two
particles and the final of the two
particles and the corresponding energy
conservation is the K plus k1 prime
equals K Prime that's the final plus a
cable
on prime final and let's see just a wait
hold on this and because the HK HK that
gives me momentum later on I'll make a
say a modification to this form here you
can see this is a simple momentum
conservation but later on we'll add as
in crystal you add a reciprocal lattice
G and that's a so-called unclamp process
but basically those transition rate also
give you I say in doing the math also
you'll actually get the energy and the
momentum conservation and most of time
you can say people do not like to write
those integers that's why the derocker
if you read the quantum mechanics book
they will write Dirac notation and the
Dirac notation for this is your initial
state interacting that's like a wave
function here interaction with perturb
the Hamiltonian and goes to final state
so that represent this integral and you
have this integration okay and you also
write this as a matrix form F I square
so there are three different ways to do
quantum mechanics why is the matrix do
the Heisenberg Dirac notation Dirac and
Schrodinger is the Schrodinger equation
okay they are all equivalent okay so
this is the famous Fermi Golden Rule
next time you heard from the Golden Rule
you're not it and this is set
so that gives you the transition rate
from the instant initiative families are
given the interaction Hamiltonian this
is by showing the time-dependent
schrodinger equation using the
perturbation method okay so that's a
first step right we say we're dealing
with the coalition and now coming back
to the board's my equation I'm looking
at one particle and this particle can
collide with many particles in the
system right so I have to counter all
the other possibilities and so the now I
can start right here DT this collision
term DF DT this collision first if this
particle is collide two other states
that I have a loss right you go in from
the original e-k states to e prime K
Prime States then this F because the F
is represented in the one particle at a
specific estate so I lose a partner in
that state so my first term is going out
that's a loss so I have a little sign so
it's going out right and of course that
depends on I see the rate that really
depends if I have the rate here
collision rate out for two quantum
states but then I need to say each
quantum states how many particles I have
right so I need to say F really the
initial T are K and if we cry the ways
the other 1t are similar location k1 all
right so how many inkay how many in k1
and what's the rate of going from ok K 1
to K prime k1 k1 prime so this is where
the Fermi good and rule tells me those
are how many to start with ok so this is
the loss and now because I'm counting
one specific so I need to really say sum
up all other possibility so need to sign
up with k1 I need to sum up ok pride I
need to sell my lucky 1 prime that
summation is actually because each K is
a wave vector its vector right it's
actually each of this case 3 submission
so I have really nice summation K 1 is a
vector K prime is vector and hay 1 prime
is vector this is loss and then there's
again that's going from the reverse see
how many K prime K 1 prime they scatter
and scatter back into the current state
ok so begin is from T R so here this is
where the boys my equation were the
molecular chaos assumption we use before
right so it's only interacting at our
point so I'm not writing a different our
point I mentioned that there are
modification people try to consider
final size of the atom or molecule like
Conn's [ __ ] equation in that case you
have to add it to different our point
that becomes a lot more complicated so
here I have K Prime that's they from the
initial state is K Prime and T are same
and k1 prime right and they will
interact and go in from K prime K 1
Prime
go into K k1 but what I care is really
just this one specific quantum state in
K so I need to sum again all those other
states so this is a k1 K prime K 1 Prime
so this is summation index as I said so
this is out this is the in is that I'm
doing the number balance and you put in
that summation into left hand side right
hand side of the board my equation you
get the full boards my equation okay now
you can say this was just a starter the
real thing is the complication is on the
right hand side and most time we do not
write this as a summation you can use
what you learn how to change the
summation into integration right K is
the sum in the quantum states now you
need to convert that summation into
integration as long as all the
assumption we made say apply here so if
you convert this summation into
integration what you have in terms of
number of integrations
line each of this is a vector right so
you have a line let's do the integrals
and of course so you win converts data
you do - L say the distance B is 2 PI
over L so you you have that distance so
you have all this constant from
converting summation into integration
and you have a line Leslie integrals and
this line let's say in the gosh is a DK
1 vector so I can write a 3 this is a DK
1 XD k 1 yd k 1 z right and D K Prime
and the DK 1 Prime
so this is a from converting summation
to integration the second comment is
this doublet it turns out the one could
argue that this w equals this w that's a
detailed balance at the equilibrium in
when everything is a is the same scatter
out the equals scatter in otherwise you
have this one study either will be
depleted completely or it goes to blue
to infinite right that's the detailed
balance so because of that you have the
equality so you rather than write in two
terms you can split right in to combine
into one term so at the end what I can
write this scattering term df/dt say
equals now put the legatus on the first
term in the front I have then W and F T
are K and the F T are K 1 so this is the
first term - let me write this here the
second term is say F so -
f T R K Prime and the F T r k1 prime let
me just make a a another comment and
here I'm writing to fix particles you
when you do a real problem whether for
example when you electron interact with
the photon at the end of the electron
the photon may be absorbed right so you
don't have a photon coming off so for
each of this specific case you need to
carefully write down this F here I'm
just writing a generic way alpha if I
have two particle comes in collide with
each other I have two particle goes up
but say when you actually like you here
you have photons get absorbed for them
disappear right so you need to do each
of this case just using the same idea do
your detail expression so you read the
different papers different problem this
will be different expressions okay so
now go to solve this yes probably going
to be doing this America Li and then
because this also has to have the
assumption that these functions are
slowly varying right for like every
intestinal stuff yeah so so so you
integrate quit that's true say you can
do go back to summation but then they'll
remember in the past right before
computer is very powerful people always
try to say whether I can solve it
numerically I'm an actually right but
say so so that's the and in fact I say
most of time this function doesn't
change that rapidly so that's a valid
approximation they it's not as bad as I
say the line integral the reason is
that you see we have coalition you have
this Delta functions right so it's those
Delta function in energy conservation
and the Delta in momentum conservation
this is also Delta function right was
significantly constraint what are the
possible values you have to consider
okay so that's the C that will allow you
to simplify and then make this still see
trackable but I have to say that solving
full boards my equation now I'm not
going to write combine the left hand
side to the right hand side right
left hand side to right hand side what
you really have is a differential on the
left integral equation on the right
right so you and so even though you are
solving one specific state which is K
you have to consider all the other K in
your system or the quantum state in your
system to solve this distribution
functions and in transport of course if
your temperature is changing you'll see
as a function R so every point you
consider all the K and you swap you so
the way that people some people try to
swap their for each of this field there
are not many twice it's pretty
complicated problem right and let's say
you typically do a iterative solution
because say this one is the first
specific Hey but this integration in was
all other states right your solution has
to meet those orders requirements okay
so it's an integral differential
equation
and the integration is in k-space
the differentiation in both say real
space are and the p.k space right but
this is very hard and this equation the
Boltzmann equation is used by electrical
engineer it's the foundation you can
derive all the electrical or the
equation y electrical engineer use and
it's used a lot of all the pasta
literature is on gas dynamics rarefied
gas dynamics a lot of studies in
rarefied gas dynamics - another reason
why there are so many studying guests in
it
this is due to a polo project why
because say when you try to send the
spaceship through the atmosphere when
you go outside the IOC go to outer
atmosphere the pressure is very low the
molecule mean free path is very long so
it's in the rarefied gas flow regime
it's a lot of study in rarefied gas
dynamics and in 1960 region s a time
time scale not of studying in Neutron
you go to look at the electron transport
right there are a lot of work this is a
strong Neutron boards my equation so you
got the little Tron boards my equation
you got a gas boards my equation you get
the electron boards my equation right
you can do the electron and a photon and
photon I teach another course the
radiation transfer at the end that we
solve this equation for the photons
that's when you completely ignore the
face of the particles of those waves so
this is a that's why really there are
not many equations if you start from
here you can derive all the equations
every field or mimosa fail to use in
this transport regime right but it's a
molecular chaos assumption so this is
only valid when the particles are dilute
that's why so far been doing electron
photon photon molecules more on a
parallel path I can't deal you can use
the words my equation for liquid that's
not right okay now moving on
this is a hard equation to solve so
there is a creative way to make this
simple and that creative way now we have
both my equation right so we do
relaxation time approximation
I say I can deal with this nasty
integrals so what I'm going to write is
you will be happy
forget about the line integral okay
and this is the relaxation time okay and
now you will feel that we can probably
do something and this relaxation time
approximation again there different
field has a different name you put it in
this relaxation time on the right hand
side our boards my equation
you go to verify gas dynamic or gas
dynamic book it will not be called
Boersma equation you'll be called a
crook equation right so in the gas
dynamic that will be crook equation and
another field people don't call the
crook equation so I remember once I was
given a seminar and say a question was
the I are not so on board by equation a
strong crook equation good initial know
who is the crook okay Oh what is the
crook equation okay so are the Y it's a
relaxation time and if you put in the
right-hand side and let's forget the
spatial dependence then what I have is
DF DT equals so if your your system the
uniformly disturbed from an equilibrium
F 0 is the equilibrium distribution okay
then you can say here if you solve this
system will return f
to equilibrium f0 equals say exponential
T over top so you can see this
exponentially relaxed back to
equilibrium
that's why how is called a relaxation
time right and typically we'll call this
boys my equation under relaxation time
approximation sometimes people also call
the linearized Boersma equation but
there some confusion there I think so
now let's go to discuss what's the
relaxation time right what's this slick
scatter and let's look at a different
relaxation times different process
scattering in general when I think about
the scattering and relaxation process of
course we can say we mentioned before
photon absorption right so if I have a
before we say okay this is my the
problem when you work on right this is
my semiconductor with a band gap with
vector so you know it's a 3d and if I
have photon comes in excite from here to
here and the photon momentum is very
small so when I do my energy
conservation this is the electron
initial energy and this is a balanced
energy and finally initial energy you
also have the 400 right it's a two
particle so initially I have electron at
a II sort of energy and initially in my
Photon
has energy H nu right and the finally
the electron has energy EF so I have my
energy conservation is the EF masse I
this is the initial electron energy that
equals H bar Omega H nu that's a photon
energy and the momentum is at AF equals
K I so the final momentum of the
electron plus the photon h-bar K of the
photon
right and of course the photon
wavelength is a micron typically right
if one micron is a one point one about
the Y electron volts and the band gap is
typically electron volt few electron
volts or point one electron volts right
so you can say that the wavelength
lambda is of the order of 1 micron and
here the zone boundary is PI over a as
lattice constant right lattice constant
is the unstrung so you can see that say
lambda is really doesn't shift to this
the photon moment that does not shift
the K much it's just a very little
change so it's essentially a vertical
transition in this case and that's the
homework problem you did know the the
midterm problem you did right and of
course you can extend this if you do a
indirect gap semiconductor like Silicon
and say silicon I have a valence band
here conduction band is another minimum
is somewhere here right this is a
silicon or indirect gap in general and
now when the energy of the photon is
right at a gap you can say there is no
enough momentum right the photon cannot
leave
the electron from here to here long
because the momentum K is not enough so
what it does is you will interact you
actually have three particle right you
like to interact with the full town and
the interactor with the full on fold on
very small energy mini wave eight to ten
some mini B and the wave vector on the
other hand the momentum is large so you
can write the your in that case you say
okay my the say indirect gap if this
transition happen you will involve say
both electron photon and the photon and
DF equals 3 I plus h-bar Omega photon
and it could be plus minus h-bar Omega L
follow so well then plus minus means if
it's a plus a absorb solar full on get
in
if the Manas a following emitted right
so that's your energy conservation now
you have three particles in Wahb and a K
F equals ki + H Bar K photon which you
can neglect and in the case of fall and
this energy is a steer you you should
carry the UV in your analysis but this
one is pretty small and plus minus H Bar
K fallen so ah now if you can do this
problem you should be able to do this
problem using the joint density try to
write down this Jordan state joined
incident of states and say if you have
an indirect gap semiconductor how the
absorption will change near the bang gap
right
so those are the things now you can
apply and of course what I say whether
the be general behavior is for direct
gap this is your energy gap eg
and you have a very sharp rise in the
absorption by the indirect gap it could
be lower fold on right absorption or
higher but the rate will be much smaller
okay and that's the we mentioned before
this is a problem of silicon when you
try to use as a solar cell because this
absorption is not very strong which
people means you can have to use very
thick material to absorb the photon to
capture it and that is the cost of the
matures yes oh yeah
oh that's what this is a very good
question it's a read problem it's a rate
right so high whether it happens if you
have absorbed and I think I say you
probably can have some mismatch due to
the uncertainty principle but I do not
see you so you sometimes you can see you
reach that of virtual state and then you
need the other scent to come in but they
say that's a very short so you almost
instantaneously you have to have that so
that that's a lot of reason why this one
is the smaller right the scattering
matrix will be weaker and the that's in
this region is a smaller yes
right how c-could you what's a question
again right right well you you don't
have a say this is you can't shifted
this one there are some idea how to
shift it the idea to shift it is using
quantum size effect that's the first
problem
I give BAC in the quiz the short problem
now when you use very small so what
happens is this one will rise right the
Lex let the first level will become here
rather than at the bottom and if it's
small enough this one right here and be
lower than that that depends on the
effective mass it's a if this is a sharp
this is a very very say the the
flattened means the large effective mass
that means you need a much smaller
diameter to raise it so you have to look
at the effective mass of history ban and
of course when you make smaller this
we're also going down and the some of
the you see this is the first problem is
you have to consider what's going up for
the conduction band which goes down you
multiply when the effective mass is same
you multiply by a factor of two that's
how you you nagy the bandgap okay so
this is a photon well maybe I can make
it one more common religion while
requestion
right some people say okay let me
develop a intermediate band gap solar
shell right what does that mean this is
a band gap right and some of the
infrasound is not absorbed because
there's not enough energy so the idea is
okay let me develop our energy level in
the gap by putting outer atoms so
quantum dots in the region right and
then the you free photon out can go from
here to here the first fold huh and then
the second photon go from here to here
it's a nice idea that's hard to do why
this is a matter of the time receive
your time right
you need the electron to here and it has
a tendency to get lost the competition
this is all rigged right you relax back
or you interact with the fold and become
heat then you lost so you have a city
say if you can stay there long enough
wait for the legs full-time to come to
lift it you can go to calculate roughly
back up in oval you malobi if we have
certain photon density coming in how
line takes for the legs photon to come
in with that certain energy right so in
the other way is say there also the
so-called two photon absorption what
happens is it is two photon comes in at
the same time and same place and they
get that transition but you can see in
that case what they need it's very high
flux right because we need to come at
the same time the same location so you
need a lot of day so long linear optics
this two photon absorption they require
very high intensity you use lasers to do
that and in fact many times you need a
very high intensity lasers to get a
nonlinear regime so it's all related to
the rate at the time when you think
about what's possible alright there's a
concept there you this is rate concept
is very important right how fast is the
process and you can dream for example I
have all say some electron comes it
photon comes in right
I can leave to the electron say
sometimes I can have absorption from
here to here free carrier absorption and
I say okay
oh I have a high energy photon comes in
right
because of the solar spectrum have a lot
of photon like that you raise the
electron here isn't a good if you take
this electron energy out rather than go
back to here most solar see all these
electron will go here do you take it out
from here to here is about peak off
second okay timescale so you look at the
whole line takes a 1 picosecond and how
much electron will travel you say that's
very hard right so it's this reprocess
those are the very important getting
this order right so this is a we say ok
energy tries for energy conversion
what is it this is energy conversion did
you say right the energy is going from
photon to electron and there are of
course many competing process if you do
a device and the other process you you
like to a full on once you get the
electron and fold unfold on so let's
look at photon : so far when we talk of
photon we did dispersion we did the
Sprint
maths prints right that's the idea
harmonic oscillator and they do not
interact if I just have harmonic
oscillator photon is a harmonic
oscillator fold on do not interact okay
so it's the an harmonic term that will
cause that interaction and for photon
for long in fact it's hard to get a
photon talk to each other interact with
each other like I say nonlinear optics
in either very large flocks to get them
together right but with the photon which
is in the salt in solid the latter
let's say this is a potential we draw
before and the harmonic approximation is
approximate this point that by problem
right so here is the potential here is
distance and but see if you write down
the high order term right this is the
minimum and the first order is gone 1/2
of K X minus X 0 square so that's a
harmonic term right and then you have an
harmonic the next term is an harmonic so
you expand your potential using Taylor
expansion is d DX squared c x0 and x2
minus x0 cubed all right zero order
first order gong second order third
order you can write full shoulder now
you do your spring constant your force
is the DF do my DX right of course you
gather your sprinter harmonicas spring
term that's what we use we do met the
photon dispersion but if you go to your
next term your higher order term you'll
get ax X minus x0 squared right that's
the third order term so that gives you
another spring innerspring along in your
spring right now if you have two photons
each one has a one specific frequency
you do their product of the two funa
right Omega 1 sine Omega 1 times Omega T
1 T times sine when we got to a tutti
what do you get you get a plus mallas
right that's a long linear term so you
start will have the two sine waves
interact with each other if you have
those nonlinear term otherwise it's just
an inertia proposition the you will
never change the frequency so this is
the source of for long photon
interaction and they come
Megaforce term gives you the pot because
of this you can say if I have Omega one
comes in I Omega two comes in you can go
on guys three that's the Sun so what it
means is a two-fold on becomes one or
you can have one photon split it into
two alright so you have the Omega 1
Omega 2 Omega 3 and in the process you
have energy and momentum conservation
this is a Chi Omega 1 plus Omega 2
equals H Omega 3 that's for the this one
is the C absorption process and in
foreign language we don't call that
absorption we see that an inhalation
I don't i okay I say maybe I should not
pronounce the H inhalation right
animation you agree and here is a
creation right one becomes two so this
is a creation process so create say for
this so you can write the corresponding
energy conservation
now momentum conservation is interesting
and normally I would write H Bar K 1
plus h-bar K 2 equals H Bar K 3 this is
a lot more and in fact this is called
normal process
okay but no more process that scattering
I should do not create a resistance to
fall he flew why is that let's think
about the vector format we just did
right so what I have if I draw that as a
momentum conservation so this is a h-bar
K 1 H Bar K 2 and this is when they
combine the form H Bar K 3 right that's
a longer process now originally I have
h-bar K 1 is carrying a heater h-bar
Omega 1 and H Bar K 2 is the current
here the H bar Omega 2 now if it's a
normal process this final one is a
carrying an energy of Omega 1 plus Omega
2 that's the same as original right and
also the direction is the sum of the two
so essentially the latter in fact is if
I have heat flow this cradle and heat
flow in this direction this final one is
a steel current that same heat mount of
heat flow in the same direction right
so this normal process actually do not
create the resistance and what happens
is if I think about the dispersion so
phonon dispersion right transfers
non-shooting and so you have to consider
photon from each different branches
whether they can satisfy the energy
conservation alright this is a K and a
specific direction Omega
and sometimes to say when this one go
beyond the hk1 let's say here is a k2 k1
k2 go beyond the Brillouin zone get a
much larger K and in that case the
crystal symmetry the reciprocal lattice
here this point G right it could be
another direction G I'm just drawing on
the same branch but it could be
completely different branch two photons
interact right and the if you do the
wave analysis so what's the matter
allowable process is a h-bar K 1 plus
h-bar K 2 is 4 so H Bar K 3 plus h-bar G
this is G is the reciprocal lattice
vector right in chapter 4 we talked
about that the Fourier transform of a
crystal lattice point into Fourier space
this Fourier space has a corresponding
lattice constant G and that G is that G
okay and this process by adding another
vector G you could go complete different
random directions that's not the
original heat flow direction so it's
this process it still has the energy
conservation but the direction change
due to the crystal same momentum here
this created resistance and this is
called a UN Club process
it's a German war
I think I'm not sure say but this
explanation come from perish perish see
was a parish I think this is a British
guy I don't know why the way this is a
unclamp okay but say I remember when I
was a student I actually heard a talk
similar given by pears he was in the 90s
at Berkeley and he told an interesting
story
and he say he no lambda and I'm not sure
say the NIF just under book that's if
you read through that book you
understand everything say none though he
said none though was telling people they
say he's a server I say he considered
him saying himself by the third read
scientist okay
and so people asked him who is the first
rate he's a Einsteins first rate who is
the second rate Heisenberg DeRogatis
after secondary so he's early
okay now I'm trying to read myself
okay so this unclamp process create
resistance for the heat flow okay and
they are different differently so people
have used that those kind of four so you
use the Fermi golden rule and derive
some expressions but those for example
for uncom process the relaxation time is
one expression that's used is the by
temperature and K T KB T that's in the
exponent
t cubic on gas work okay but I want to
caution you this were actually done in
the 50s another approximation made in
this derivation and one for example calm
approximation is the by model which is
an inner approximation to the dispersion
right you know it's not going to be
valid when you go to high frequency high
wave vectors and so they're they're
different for low more process their
expression unclamp process they're
approximation and also there are unknown
constants and those constants is the
scatter matrix and if you do know so
typically people use this as a feeding
parameter and that's a full-on photon
scattering now they are safe or what
other scatter for long are the
impurities right you have the harmonic
oscillator you have silicon and then you
dope it Udo boron no phosphor right this
has a different match and the will so
when there are waves comes in say a
different mass you'll be scattered and
this scatter is typically so impurity
scattering
and remember last time I say phonon
phonon scattering the count is that you
can trigger the complete face
randomizing because top up here pop-up
there you can fix the position right but
we have impurity scattering this
impurity atom some fixed it's just so
you can't you normally do know where
they are right and the impurity
scattering form is typically reading as
fourth power inverse here you can see
our alright humours okay
so in fact that this is a result nada
derived it's a result from light and if
you look at the sky it's a blue sky and
that's because the light is scattered by
the density fluctuation of the gas or
small particles and so when you have
small atoms or small particles you can
say the higher frequency this higher how
is the this is how right how itself is a
smaller the left of the relaxation time
that means is scatter more often right
so that's why the sky is blue right
that's the real a scatter it's a real a
scattering acoustic waves and say after
your waves they all have those
characteristics and by say it's not
completely sure what inward regime this
is a applicable for Christy or for
atomic weights and this is the still
some debate there right and finally this
is a boundary there is also boundary if
there's no scattering hits a boundary
there's bondage scanner and that's the
one that will actually solve boards my
equation using this as a boundary
condition
my equation we can trigger more
rigorously but typically in the past
people we do is when you have different
relaxation time you pass them together
right particularly if they are all
randomly distributed in the volume and
you do this total tau equals the
different process inverse so it's more
resistive one the more frequently
scatter one that will be dominant right
because this is all you merge and this
is the Matheson rule okay so that's you
put all these different process together
one final comment so here is the photon
photon scattering and then you have a
electron photon scattering right we have
a electron has certain energy interact
with the photon get into a different
energy E E Prime and also in the process
you have the energy momentum
conservation and this scattering of
course you deal with the electron
transport that's very important right
you'll actually engineer always try to
improve their mobility try to make a
faster device you want to reduce the
fall off scatter and so the the once I
want to comment here is of course the
energy change process if there's energy
change is inelastic right the energy is
not conserved see the particle energy
change during this scatter and the
impurity scattering I get the really
scattered we typically this
the elastic scattering the elastic
scattering frequency doesn't change and
in fact a rigorous speaking rigorously
speaking for all in elastic scattering
process where the energy change that
approximation the relaxation time
approximation is not valid we do it
audit hi but this actual regression are
valid so you go once we go to chapter 8
we have one more step let's suppose you
split this C into two terms rather than
just a relaxation turn so that's when we
deal with the electron for long and the
line equilibrium between electron for
now okay so I think I will stop on this
topic and now I think we'll come to the
stage I would say you should pick up a
day and as I said at the beginning any
journal and you should not be saying
you're sure that the should not be
afraid of really right I'm sure that you
can understand everything but what I'm
hoping is there always a sense that will
help you to to get some idea of all of
those different many papers so let's
take a quick look
so say all the I think I have covered
most of the basic concepts and the rest
is if you read paper of course I say the
concept that need time to digest and why
was I was a quickly look at that let's
say nano letter now you can look at the
whole I would say you should look at all
the knowledge earners
this is a - okay so ah silicon nanowire
this is a more the device really there
right
I thought we can look either the current
issue where is the current issue more
matures so you really make how to make a
material so that that's a relatively
easy right okay for example if you go to
next one let's prepare by David Smith he
was a guy first to delegate of
refraction experiment and the surface
plasmons if you look at the title
locally taunt surface plasmon resonance
you heard surface plasma you can read
and see what what what it means what's
it doing and if I look at this one right
I didn't open but you can go to check
whether I guess that is right so if I
look at this electric breakdown on/off
state like this we just starts to a
graphene Junction probably there okay
breakdown of course the the it can
create the gaps but there also could be
tunneling phenomena if you have virtual
arrow gaps electron tunneling I don't
know whether paper will deal with those
issues right and that's where I stopped
water you have to wait when we do the
linear more Einstein treatment linear
response theory and we look at battery
one concept I'll go into another
directly on battery but you have to
understand what is the electrochemical
potential okay and conducting graphene
nano nano tubes so I is to see my
message to you is now you go to the
spool journal and try to say rate
through the title and guess what is
doing you under you plow the few papers
and you try to read through the the
content it is not of us a concern yeah
does this help you pass a call and say
the call is asking to read papers right
and you see there will ask your
questions so that's I think issue help
but no guarantee okay